Merhaba hepinize
Öncelikle Bahçeköy açı listesine bana bu
fırsatı verdiği için çok teşekkür ederim
sizinle buluşmak beni mutlu ediyor
böyle bir konuşma yapacağımı
öğrendiğim zaman ne anlatabilirim diye
çok uzun boylu düşündüm
Şunu fark ettim
anlatabilecek kadar çok şey biliyor
muyum diye bayağı düşündüm bunun üzerine
sonra
halihazırda
2022 senesinde
içinde bulunduğum ruh durumunu
sizinle paylaşmak istediğimi fark ettim
içinde bulunduğum ruh durumu karışık ama
etrafıma baktığımda pek çok insanın da
karışık olduğunu görüyorum
Halbuki çok sevdiğim bir şeyi yapıyorum
oyunculuk yapıyorum drama sanatı ile
ilgileniyorum
oyunculuk yapacağımı bilmiyordum böyle
bir şey seçeceğimi bilmiyordum
küçükken
küçükken bir akrabamız
aileyi çok güldürdü taklitler yaparak
Ben de onun gibi taklitler yapmaya
başladım
sonra bu Ortaokulda devam etti lisede
devam etti tiyatro kollarına girdim
Orada kendimi mutlu hissetmeye başladım
bir meslek olacak mıydı hayatımı
belirleyecek miydi Hayatımda çok büyük
bir yer tutacak mıydı onu bilmiyordum
Çok ciddi bir yönlendirme olmadığı için
de mesela üniversitede fizik bölümüne
girdim ben
Çünkü Lisede Bir hocamız sizin Kafanız
hiç çalışmıyor sizden fiziki fizikçi
olmaz demişti bize fizik hocamız Ben de
ona inat fizikçi olmak üzere
üniversiteye girdim üniversiteye fizikçi
olmak üzere girdim ben lise Hocama İnat
soru Üniversiteye girince ve Fizik
okumaya başlayınca hocaya inat fizikçi
olunmaz dedim Ne yaptım
beşeri bilimler hüman etiyesi okumak
istiyorum diye düşündüm ekonomiye geçti
4 sene ekonomi okudum ve Ekonomist
olarak üniversiteden mezun oldum
ama hala çok istediğim şeyi yapamıyordu
büyük bir şansım vardı üniversitede
Boğaziçi Üniversitesi oyuncuları ile
birlikte çalışma şansım oldu Onlar bu
işi ciddiye alan arkadaşlardı ve hepimiz
bu işi biraz ciddiye almayı öğrendik Bu
sayede ve Ben üniversitenin son
sınıfında
1986 senesinde
birsak tiyatro Atölyesi diye bir ilan
gördüm gazetede
rahmetli rejisör oyuncu beklenen algının
başında olduğu bir Eğitmen ekibi orada
oyunculuk dersi veriyordu haklı oraya
girdim
beklenen Alkan hocamla tanıştım benim
üzerimde çok büyük bir etkisi vardı
bebeklerin Alkan Hoca ile beraber
oyunculuğun
paket ekmekten ibaret olmadığını
başkalarını güldürmekten ibaret
olmadığını aslında ve Aslında hikaye
anlatmak üzerine olduğunu öğrendim
hikaye anlatmak çok önemliydi bu çünkü
hikaye anlatmakla denen şeyin
hayatımızda ne kadar önemli olduğunu
bilmiyordum orada yavaş yavaş keşfetmeye
başladım
hayatımızın en önemli
eğlencelerinden avuntularından
amaçlarından birinin hikaye anlatmak ve
Hikaye dinlemek olduğuna inanıyorum
hepimiz hikaye anlatmak ve Hikaye
dinlemek üzerine bir içgüdüyle dünyaya
geliyoruz
senaryo yazımı üzerine okuduğum
kitaplardan birinde bir çocuğun
10 yaşında bile olmayan bir çocuğun
başından geçen bir şeyi anlatırken
dinleyenleri merak edecek şekilde
kurguladığını öğrenmiştim öyle yazıyordu
orada Peki bunu nasıl yapabiliyoruz Bu
bir İçgüdü olarak bizde var çünkü
hikayelere büyük ihtiyaç duyuyorum
hikayeler sayesinde
öğreniyoruz Hatta ve hatta dedikodu
yapıyoruz
başkaları hakkında konuşuyoruz onları
değerlendiriyoruz kendimizi
değerlendiriyoruz ve Hatta bize
benzemeyenleri yani ötekileri anlamaya
başlıyoruz hikayeler hayatımızda çok
büyük bir yer tutuyor çok büyük bir yer
tutuyor
bunu fark ettiğim zaman da
oyunculara daha büyük bir sevgi ile
asılmaya başladığını fark ettim ve onun
üzerine çalışma yapmaya başladım
oyunculuk işin Bir kısmıyla Aslında
genel olarak dramayla çok ilgilendiğimi
fark ettim Nasıl kuruyoruz kurguluyoruz
etki nasıl yaratıyoruz bu oyunculukta
nasıl oluyor senaryo yazımında nasıl
oluyor hikaye yazarken nasıl oluyor
Roman yazarken nasıl oluyor drama hikaye
anlatmak nasıl oluyor bunun üzerine
çokça kafa patlatmaya başladım ve kafa
yapmaya başladıktan sonra da mutlu oldu
bu fark ettim
şu da
Yürek içinde kafamı kurcalamaya başladı
oyunculukla ilgilendikçe oyunculuğu
anlamayı öğrenmeye başladıkça
[Müzik]
EGO meselesinin EGO şişkinliği
meselesinin
[Müzik]
pek çok meslekte olduğu gibi bizim
mesleğimizde de çok ciddi bir Ayak bağı
olduğunu fark etmeye başladım
eğitim sırasında beklenen Algan hocamız
ilk işiniz egolarınızdan kurtulmak derdi
O zaman çok anlamazdım sonra zaman
içinde anlamaya başladım insanın
kendisine verdiği büyük önem ve kendini
çevresinin giderek gezegeninin giderek
kainatın merkezinde hissetmesi özelliği
en büyük ayak bağlarımızdan bir tanesi
[Müzik]
çok afralanıyoruz safralanıyoruz çok
kasılıyoruz ediyoruz şişiniyoruz ama
baktığınızda oyunculuk
dünyanın en tehlikeli mesleği değil
ezberinizi unutursanız kimse ölmüyor
sahnede bir aksilik olduğunda kimse
ölmüyor ama bir pilot hata yaptığında
bir beyin cerrahı hata yaptığında çok
daha büyük çok daha ağır sonuçlarla
karşılaşabiliyorsunuz
Yani lafı unutursanız bir şey olmuyor
Ama lafı unutursanız yapmanız gereken
şeyleri unutursanız hikayenizi
anlatmakta eksik kalıyorsunuz hikayenin
anlatılmasını eksik kalması da
büyük bir eksiklik yoksulluk duygusu
yaratıyor karşı tarafta
bunlarla uğraşırken
oyunculuk öğrendikçe giderek daha zevk
almaya başlamışken bana büyük heyecan
vermeye başlamışken
konuşmanın başında da söylediğim gibi
2022'ye geldiğinizde
Hatta giderek son 5-10 sene içerisinde
büyük bir
yalnızlık duygusu içine girdiğimi fark
ettim Bu yalnızlık duygusunda Yalnız
olmadığımı farkındayım
mesela
hikaye anlatmanın çok önemli olduğunu
söyledim ama şimdi hikayeden
bir sosyal medya uygulamasındaki
story'yi anlayabiliyoruz ve ömrü 24 saat
kelimelerin içini boşalmasından
bahsediyorum bir anlamda hikayeler bir
fotoğraf koyuyoruz
o fotoğraf 24 saat sonra ortadan
kayboluyor ve onun adı hikaye oluyor
gerçeklikle bağımızın
kopmaya başladığını hissediyorum
kelimelerin içinin boşalmaya başladığını
hissediyorum kelimelerle anlatmakla çok
işi olan bir insan olarak boşalmaya
başladığını istiyor hissediyorum
ya mesela içinde bulduğum bulunduğumuz
kainatın bize yetmemesi ve mesela Meta
worers diye bir şeyin ortaya çıkması
bunları anlatırken Hiç öyle muhafazakar
bir yerden söylemiyorum değişikliklere
kapalı bir yerden söylemiyorum fakat
içinde bulunduğumuz sitenin kölenin
gezegenin yeterince kıymetini Bilmeden
bir başkasının peşinden gitmek meselesi
beni çok büyük endişelere sevk ediyor
bir oyuncu olarak bunu çok rahatlıkla
söyleyebilirim
[Müzik]
hikayenin ömrü 24 saat
paylaşmak denilen şey
paylaşmak denilen ki ne kadar çok
paylaştığımızın farkındasınız değil mi
Ne kadar çok şey paylaşıyoruz haberleri
paylaşıyoruz bilgileri paylaşıyoruz ama
paylaşmak öyle bir şey değil ki
paylaşmak iki tarafın birbirine verdiği
bir şey hakiki o şekilde paylaşma oluyor
fakat biz sürekli paylaşıyoruz şehir
butonu var ya düğme yerine buton demeye
başladığımızdan beri ona bastığınız
antiden itibaren paylaşmış oluyoruz
bastığımız zaman
like'lamış beğenmiş oluyoruz düğmeler
Biz ve bir duygu bağı olmadan bir şeyler
gidip geliyor Bir oyuncuyu bu kadar
yalnızlaştıran ve çaresiz hissettiren
bir şey ki ben
kendimi çok çok güvensiz hissediyorum bu
anlattığım sebeplerle ilgili olarak çok
çok çılgınca bir faaliyet içerisinde çok
çılgınca bir koşuşturma içerisindeyiz
ama ne kadar durup dinlemeye anlamaya
empati kurma ya
zamanımız oluyor onu bilmiyorum
büyük bir zamansızlıktan yakınmakla
beraber sahilden paylaşıp
paylaşmadığımızda emin değilim Hatta
paylaşmadığımızı düşünüyorum sahiden
beğendiğimizde emin değilim Hatta
beğenmediğinizi düşünüyorum
like düğmesine çok sık basıyor olsak da
tenimi güvensiz hissettiğimi söylemiştim
4 Derdim Var Benim
konuşma üzerine düşünürken özetlemeye
Çalıştım çalıştım bunlardan bir tanesi
dikkatimi toplayamıyorum ben yani
odaklanmakta zorluk çekiyorum
şundan dolayı
hayatımızda çok büyük bir uğultulun
çok büyük bir gürültünün eşlik ettiğini
düşünüyorum
durdurak bilmeyen bir uğultu yani
hakikaten ne yapacağımızı şaşırıyormuşuz
gibi geliyor bana
dinlemeden fikir belirtiyoruz fikir
üretiyoruz söylüyoruz
dayanılmaz bir hale geliyor Bu ve insanı
paralize edebiliyor felç edebiliyor
notunu almıştım
Amerika'da oyuncu film Seymen
hayatına son verdiğinde yeni bir başka
Amerikalı Onun için şöyle demişti
aramızdaki en duyarlılar için gürültü
çok fazla olabilir Çok fazla olabilir
devamlı bir konuşma devamlı bir müdahale
etme
hiç dinlememe gibi bir tuhaf halin
içerisindeyiz yeni çağın en büyük
problemlerinden birini bu olduğunu
düşünüyorum
ikinci problemim kendi başıma
kalamıyorum
sürekli bir uyaran bombardımanı
altındayım ve bir uyaran bombardımanı
altında olmak sanki adetmiş ve doğru bir
şeymiş gibi bu hiç bitmiyor Herkes tek
başına kalabilmek çok güzel bir şey
Yalnızlığa mahkum olmaktan bahsetmiyorum
Ama tek başına kalabilmek çok güzel bir
şey bunu yapamaz hale geldiğimi fark
ediyorum
Çünkü zamanımın çoğu düşünmekten çok
konuşmakla geçiyor
sessizliğe tahammülümüz kalmadı galiba
içimizdeki sesten kendi iç sesimizden
korkuyoruz
bir başka problem yine Çağın hızının
süratinin bana dayattığı bir şey bir şey
yapmaya karar verdiğimde yapmamayı
seçtiğim diğer şeylerin
daha güzel olabileceği endişesini
taşıyorum
bunu seçersem Onları dışarıda bırakırsam
çok şey kaçırıyor muyum seçimlerinde
kendimden eminim ortadan kalkıyor Orhan
Pamuk bir röportajında söylemişti bir
cumartesi akşamı yazmaya masanızın
başına oturduğunuzda karşı pencerede bir
parti olduğunu görüyorsanız ve buna
rağmen canınız onu çekmeden yazmaya
devam edebiliyorsanız çok başarısız
demektir bunu yapmakta zorlanıyorum
bütün bu saydığım saymaya çalıştığım
şeylerden biri
şeylerden dolayı
hikayelerle baş başa kalamamak onları
değerlendirememek Onları dinleyememek
onlara kulak verememek gibi çok ciddi
bir sorunla karşı karşıyayız Bunun böyle
olduğunu bildiğim için sahneye
çıktığımda ve bir hikaye anlatmaya aracı
olmaya
çalıştığında kendimi yalnız hissediyorum
insanların dikkatlerinin dağınık
olduğunu hissediyorum Bana bana
verecekleri 3-5 dakika 10 dakika 15
dakika 20 dakikayı vermekten çok çabuk
sıkılacaklar gibi düşünüyorum ve Aslında
bunu Somut bir şekilde de tecrübe
ediyorum Çünkü insanların ellerindeki
Telefonların ışığı cep telefonlarının
ışığı karanlık sabunda yüzlerine vuruyor
inanılmaz bir şey bütün samimiyetinizde
içtenliğinizle Emek vererek oraya bir
şey anlatmaya çıkıyorsunuz ve ciddi bir
kalabalık sürekli olarak telefonuna
bakıyor oyunu kaydediyor Halbuki orada
oyun niye Kaydediyorsun ki orada tam
karşında ben o
şeylere telefonun ışıklarını işte
salondaki Ateş böcekleri diyorum o
salondaki Ateş böcekleri yüzünden bu
salondaki Ateş böcekleri benim kendimi
güvende hissetmememin en somut
göstergesi haline dönüşüyor
büyük soru şu
bir cevap vermektense bir cevap
bulmaktansa benim yok çünkü çok fazla
ama
Oğuz Atay'ın sorusu hala geçerli Orada
kimse var mı
hakikaten yalnız mıyız Değil miyiz
bilmiyorum
bundan ibaret söyleyeceklerim çok
teşekkür ederim beni dinlediğiniz ve
bana Vakit ayırdığınız için